the autopilot relies on a series of
sensors all around the aircraft
collecting data this is captain sonia
laxo a 23-year veteran at american
airlines she like other pilots uses
autopilot on every flight and while it
controls the ailerons the flaparons and
spoilers on both wings the elevator on
the tail and as well as the rudder
autopilot isn't autonomous she's here to
explain just what it actually is how the
technology behind autopilot works and
how it helps her and her fellow pilots
get you to your destination
[Music]
quick note laxo flies boeing aircraft
and will be using boeing terminology but
autopilot works similarly on other
commercial aircraft the technical name
for the autopilot is the auto flight
control system the afcs
the afcs or autopilot is just one of an
increasing number of automated
technologies in the cockpit many of
which are designed to prevent dangerous
scenarios the autopilot system is there
to assist pilots letting them take their
hands off the yoke the main components
of the autopilot system are the
autopilot flight director system and the
auto throttle system actually controlled
by what we call the mode control panel
and the flight management computer the
fmc which we most of the time just call
it the box
the mode control panel in the box those
are both controlled by the pilots on the
flight deck by using the mode control
panel the flight management computer we
command that autopilot flight director
system and the auto throttle system to
perform the climbs the crews the
descents the approach and in certain
circumstances the actual landing itself
but the autopilot system extends outside
the cockpit
the autopilot relies on a series of
sensors all around the aircraft
collecting data gps information as well
as data on air speed and altitude are
fed back to the computers on board which
use the information to determine if a
plane is veering from its preset route
the computers are always running i mean
they're very fast speed so anytime
there's any little discrepancy it's
going to make an adjustment to keep that
aircraft on that flight profile that's
the auto part the system's ability to
make those adjustments to maintain level
flight along a path without pilot input
the autopilot is actually controlling
the flight controls so it's going to be
the ailerons the laperons and spoilers
on both wings the elevator on the tail
as well as the rudder by adjusting those
components the autopilot is able to move
the plane along one of three axes we
have the longitudinal axis from nose to
tail the lateral from wing tip to
wingtip and then the vertical which goes
straight down the middle of the aircraft
so when the aircraft is rotating on the
longitudinal axis it's using the
ailerons the flap runs and spoils to do
that and then the lateral axis that's
being used in the elevators
and then your rudder will be along the
vertical axis while autopilot can move
the plane itself it's not doing so
without supervision the autopilot
is a tool
the autopilot doesn't fly the airplane
we fly the airplane through the
automation of the autopilot
so while the autopilot is maintaining
wings level flying the route
the pilot is always monitoring the
autopilot this relationship can go both
ways however certain autopilot systems
prevent input from pilots that would for
example force the plane to turn too
sharply or raise the nose at too steep
an angle
[Music]
to understand just how a pilot uses
autopilot let's follow a flight's path
starting at the gate initially at the
gate where you download the route into
fmc the box so then the autopilot knows
what it needs to be following as per the
route and also performance airspeed fuel
consumption the autopilot isn't engaged
just yet pilots control the takeoff but
they must engage the autopilot above 28
000 feet due to vertical separation
requirements though most pilots press
the button sooner letting the autopilot
take control
analogy would be the cruise control in
your car
so it assists the driver that the driver
still has to be aware of their
environment and react to that
environment just like on the flight deck
we can disconnect the autopilot at any
and all time and have full control of
the aircraft but that isn't common
pilots typically spend only a few
minutes per trip manually flying the
plane though they are required to do
regular proficiency checks in a flight
simulator during which certain segments
of the flight must be hand flown once
autopilot is engaged pilots jobs don't
stop we're constantly working on our
tasks to ensure the safety of our
passengers getting from point a to point
b
we're not sitting up here reading the
newspaper we don't have time for that
instead pilots are monitoring the fuel
planning for emergencies and looking out
for weather ahead which could prompt
them to change their instructions for
the autopilot we can use it to either go
around the weather either using a
heading mode or actually making changes
into the route itself to go around the
weather so the one thing is we're always
aviating navigating communicating but
with safety being our number one
priority
when it comes time to land pilots
generally disengage autopilot and land
themselves but in certain types of
weather with low visibility pilots are
actually required to do an auto land you
don't have that visual output out the
window so that actually helps but you're
again watching it like a hawk and at any
point in time if it's not flying the
path it's supposed to fly we disconnect
it automation including the autopilot
system has contributed to record low
accident rates in recent years
however it was a faulty flight control
system combined with pilot missteps and
other factors that investigators say led
to two fatal crashes of boeing 737 max
in 2018 and 2019. boeing has since fixed
the system and revamped pilot training
and with the faa's approval the max is
now being used for passenger flights
again
meanwhile airplane automation is
continuing with companies testing out
increasingly advanced systems aimed at
reducing pilot workload and enhancing
safety
but for all its advances autopilot still
has a lot to learn the autopilot cannot
maneuver the aircraft from the gate to
the runway and take off nor can it
maneuver the aircraft from the runway
back to the gate for now think of
autopilot as an extra set of hands in
the air following laxo's detailed
instructions
[Music]
you